the other thing that was in the trailer
that that as people have gone crazy for
this this is Jamie's James Bond moment
when he comes from the sea it's like we
paid you to make these noises but so you
left Vancouver that isn't mine Cooper is
it that it's definitely not thank you
very much in the South of France and to
be honest we did that right at the end
of the shoot after you know this all
sort of you know massive journey and all
the stuff in France was so jet skiing
around and swimming and not gonna
boating bikes and it was actually good
bit of a whole day to be honest but that
was horrendous I mean look if they just
tilted the camera dial that whole moment
it was awful we had at the beach semi
sort of closed off but actually there
was loads of people on there that we
didn't have control over and then it was
some you know Beach down here in a big
wall and I Street up there with hundreds
of fans and paparazzi and all just
trying to get shots because the code is
wearing tiny wee bikini and I'm wearing
whatever the clobber is they so they
have this whole thing that would be like
sexy you come out of the water but it's
not a sand beach it's one of those we
pebble we did one thing and I was going
[Laughter]
we're gonna have to change something up
here help me write for the put down like
a weak carpet didn't really kind of work
it was kind of dying but they put rocks
on it to try to keep those still so but
it's still like it wasn't like a
platform and thing I still rocks
underneath and then I ended up wearing
those that look like sort of guppy shoes
in the world actually I saw I had to see
the movie last week to do press for it
ever and this whole thing I mean they
used out as a still but you don't my
exit from the thing isn't in isn't in
the movie pretty crap spoiler
[Music]